Donald Trump is signing an executive order
to label Judaism a nationality. And we actually,
we talked about this on yesterday's bonus
show. I wasn't planning on talking about it
on the broadcast show, but the amount of disinformation,
misunderstanding, and just plain old idiocy
around this makes me feel like it probably
warrants a little bit more discussion today.
So Trump's idea is that in order, or at least
what he's claiming is that it could be somebody
else's idea in order to fight antisemitism
on college campuses, you labeled Judaism and
nationality that will trigger a clause in
the 1964 civil rights act, which blocks federal
funding from any schools that allow discrimination
on the basis of nationality. That's the idea.
But there are many, many issues here to talk
about. One issue of course, and it's not even
the subject for today, but I find that it's
important to get on the record, some of what's
called antisemitism.
On college campuses is antisemitism. Some
of it is anti Israeli organizing by people
who are against Israeli foreign policy. To
be clear, there's both, and there is also
stuff that's a combination of the two. That's
not the real issue for me here. The real issue
for me here is that Judaism simply is not
a nationality. And when you label it as such,
not only is it inaccurate, you're actually
perpetuating some antisemitic tropes about
dual loyalty that is already the source of
so much discrimination and, and attacks on
Jews in the United States. So let's go through
this very carefully because it's really important
that everybody understand the completely misguided
nature of this. Judaism is three things. Judaism
is a religion. It's an ethnicity to the extent
that ethnicity exists, meaning I, if you go
back far enough, we're all just homo sapiens.
But as ethnicity and race go, Judaism is an
ethnicity and Judaism is also a cultural,
uh, group.
In fact, it's more than one. You have Eastern
European jewelry, which has sort of a different
culture in many ways. Then Yemeni jewelry,
uh, just as as one example. So I am Jewish.
Ethnically. We actually did DNA tests on the
show. We had a DNA DNA expert come on and
analyze them. My results came back. I am 100%
Ashkenazi Jew. Uh, this is a sort of sub ethnic
group of Judaism more broadly. I can't convert
into that. I can't convert out of that. That's
an ethnicity. Culturally, I'm Jewish in that
I was raised in a Jewish family eating traditional
Jewish foods, gathering with family around
Jewish holidays, and I am not religious. One
can choose to be religious or not. You can
convert into the religion of Judaism that
won't make you ethnically Jewish. Of course,
now there's nothing in there about nationality.
If someone discriminates against me for being
Jewish, they are maybe discriminating against
my ethnicity.
They may be discriminating against my cultural
group. They might be discriminating against
my perceived religion, even though I'm not
religious, but there's nothing in there about
country of origin. In fact, I was born in
Argentina. I'm now a citizen of the United
States. So when you look at my us passport,
it's an American passport. I'm an American
citizen and it says, I think, I don't remember
if it's called nationality or country of birth.
It actually might be nationality on the U
S passport. Argentina. I went to Israel one
time for nine days. Okay. Period. So at its
core, nothing about this is about nationality.
Now there are people who are defending this
decision by Donald Trump in a mildly antisemitic
way, saying Judaism is inextricably tied into
Israel because that's where the religion originates.
That's where Christianity also originated.
You don't see the same argument being made
and as nationality is defined in the United
States, it does not fit, but it's more than
just inaccurate.
When you label Judaism and nationality, it
perpetuates the antisemitic trope of dual
loyalty. Jews around the world and in the
United States have been dealing with this
for a very long time. The idea is you're American,
but you're Jewish. So there's some hidden
loyalty to Israel or to Jews over country
or whatever, such that you're not really loyal
to what's in the best interests of the United
States in the way that an American Christian
would be loyal to the United States. And this
is the source of some really, really ugly
stuff. So even if we take Trump, but he's
at his word, he doing this to fight antisemitism.
This is still a terrible idea because aside
from being factually inaccurate, it perpetuates
this idea that an American born Jew who's
never been to Israel is not even religious.
If discriminated against is being targeted
for their nationality. Think about how boneheaded
and simply incorrect that presumption would
be.
It's wrong. It's shortsighted, it's problematic,
and hopefully Donald Trump is going to be
talked out of this. Now, as with all of these
executive order things that Donald Trump does,
this was unlikely to really be Trump's idea.
Uh, this is something that in all likelihood,
somebody came to him with and said, Hey, how
about this? What do you think about doing
something like this? Here's a good idea. Here's
why it would be good. This is the group that
would be placated by it, or that group would
be placated by it. Let's do it. I don't even
imagine for a second that Donald Trump has
any kind of deeper, serious understanding
of what is implicit or, or explicit in doing
something like this. But regardless, it's
a bad idea. It shouldn't be done and it doesn't
make any sense. I do want to hear from you
about this. If you disagree, if you think
this is logical, let me know and try to do
it without perpetuating antisemitic tropes
if possible.
Right? I mean, just
with
peace
and love, I'm suggesting that to you.